c'est le vice président américain al
gore en personne qui a lancé ce cri
d'alarmé l'année dernière a été l'année
la plus chaude aux états unis depuis au
moins six ans avec de nombreux
scientifiques le vice-président
américain est inquiet du réchauffement
global de la planète le phénomène el
niño pourrait en être la cause
à titre d'exemple pour cette année cette
fois-ci l'inde traverse une période de
chaleur terrible avec des températures
qui ont atteint 50 degrés à l'ombre et
déjà provoqué la mort de près de 3000
personnes josé blanc la guerre ce n'est
pas l'eau qu'il préfère pourtant le
tigre ne quitte plus son bassin dans le
haut du continent indien
c'est pour lui une question de survie
quand la chaleur dépasse les 40 degrés
et qu'elle dure depuis plusieurs
semaines dans la rue la population se
rue sur le jus de canne et le lait de
coco lot de plus en plus rare est aussi
menacée de pollution 3000 personnes sont
mortes de déshydratation l'inde connaît
une canicule sans précédent
alors qu'elle devrait être noyé sous les
trombes d'eau de la mousson depuis plus
d'un an
le climat de la planète ne tourne plus
rond ces incendies qui touchent
actuellement la floride ont été
favorisés par une sécheresse
inhabituelle les états unis subissent
également des records de pluie et une
série de tornades qui a déjà tué 122
personnes le responsable
el niño un réchauffement excessive de
l'océan pacifique
suffisant pour chambouler le climat
d'après une étude américaine
le phénomène serait accentuée par le
réchauffement de la planète
el niño nous donne un aperçu de cette
météo extrêmement chaotique à laquelle
doivent s'attendre nos enfants et petits
enfants
en tout cas si on ne prend pas des
mesures pour inverser la tendance pour
la première fois la menace de
réchauffement climatique semble prise au
sérieux aux états unis 36 milliards de
francs vont être consacrés à la lutte
contre la pollution urbaine avec une
priorité assainir l'air que respirent la
planète